ONALD TRUMP. OF CO YETR CASUALTE
>> LET'S GO BACK TO N
>> THANKS SO MUCH.
G US NOWAPULTH
CRITICEN
G HIS  PRIMARY OPPONTS CHRISTIE
REMIND EVERNE MONDAY NIGHT
FOR A CNN TOWN WHICH IE GE.
ABE NTED TO IGHT Y
REACTINGIC ARESPONSIBLE THING T.
NOW YOU'VE REAWHAT DO YOU K?
>> JAKE,NOW, FOR
FOS WHO MAY NOMBER THIS,
THE U.S.EARS
THE FIT U.S.
COUNTRY, BROUGHT 130 POLIT
PSEDEDN
I KNS STUF
AND THE FACTTS, YOU HAVE A E
INDICTMENT, DIRECTED THE PACKING
DIRECTED WHEREY WENT WHITHEY WE,
DIRECTED THEM TO MOVE TO ER DURS
IN NEW
THESTIY UED
TD NOTU
HIS LAWYERS, JAKE, WHETHER OR
IT? WE WOULD HAVND T
ED TO GE
AND WEW THEY WOULDN'T.
ANHIS  TO MAKE
RECORD TOTT  DIRTEIDE BOXEFR HIS
OWN LAWYERT N NTS OVER TE
ARE GOING ARGUE WHO SHOULD AND.
THE BIOR O, IS THIS THE TYT  WE
TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
WAR CLPROGRAM, I WHEN EY'RE LO E
HAD  THE PO SAID
ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT
I WAS INVOLVED WITH THD I DIDN'
TO DD TRP.AIE GS WHE'R JUSTIFY T
HE ENGAGEDINWE FN
THE CONDUCT, JAKE.
T IS
ANIT IRY IT.FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEENREO ASPIREES
>> AS A FOERATTORNEY,
DOESS A CAYOU WOULD THTI
BROUGHT HAD YOU BEEN ASSIGNED?
>> I DON'T KNOW ALL THE JAKE, .
Y TELL AS
PERSON RNG T
TAPE RECORDIY HAVESSAGES ANDLS,H
DOZENS  PEOPLE
WHREROUNNALD
TRUMP  MAR-LAGR TIME.ARE ELEMEN
THE THINGS YD TO  LIKTHIS.
THOROUGHLY INVESTIGA LIKE ONLY E
UM NAUTA.ALD
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
T WRONG SIDE OF T
BEENIS IN THE BUSINE, AND
>> REPUBLICAN OF
R ELECTED OFFICIALS,
SEEM TO BE FALLING INTO THREPS.
THAT'S MOF THE ALY DEFDI DONALD
TRP.HE GROUP
OF Y GOVERNOHUTCHINS AMNEY AND I
McCARTHY SAIATL DISRUPT THTI SA
ESTION E J FOR.NGRESSMAN ANDY BT
WE'VE REACHED A,R E.
WHATO YOU MAKEE RHETORICANU MAK
LOI AGREE WITH SPETHISCT.E INDI.
BUT LET MESKWHO'S E FOT Y
IN MAYJULYST1,USED THE DOCUMENT.
AN IF YOLOOKDICTMENT, EVEN THE .
I GIVENLLDOCUS O BPOENA, AS HEE
IRLDN'T BE HEREAY
SO, EVERYONE W TE THE
AND, LOOK, I THINK T ION, DOJ,
D CO IE STEM.HAE LO
ATN MERITS.
AND TH AREOUT HERE DAMNING IN T
NA
OF CONDUCT ITO B BG ATE REALLY
BEST PERP AI
JOE BIDEN?WED BE
CONGRESS HASHEO HA
OVERSIGHT OVEREPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AND IRA T
DO IT VIGOROUSLY AND FAIRLASK A
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHAWENG.
U BADLY, EIS HOLDIO  PITTYNDAYI
E A COST TO BE
DOCUMENTS AT A POINT.
BU THEM, IF HE HADRETURNED THE S